en 1936 Picasso tenía éxito era
prolífico y se establecía en la capital
francesa Mientras tanto en España el
General Francisco Franco intentaba
derrocar a la república Y en 1937 con la
ayuda de la Alemania nazi y la Italia
fascista bombardeó la ciudad vasca de
guernica matando a 2000 civiles Ese fue
uno de los momentos más oscuros de la
Guerra Civil Española y cambió el curso
de la carrera de Picasso
Si tuvieras que elegir la época la
pintura cuál sería esa pintura cuál
sería esa época
No lo sé Es difícil de decir Todas están
hechas con diferentes intenciones son de
su época reflejan el estado del mundo en
ese momento Cuando ocurrió lo de
guernica y se guernica porque era un
desastre inmenso
International
primero tenía un proyecto para la feria
internacional de París de pintar sobre
un pintor y una modelo pero cambió de
opinión y empezó a escribir el horror de
guernica Así es como realmente giró
hacia un compromiso político muy fuerte
así que mi abuelo intentó probablemente
Mostrar lo que era la realidad Porque en
ese momento no tenías noticias
instantáneas noticias de última hora
tenías todo pocos días después y quizás
con algún tiempo de distancia la muerte
la inocencia de niños y mujeres los
animales con guernica estás en el centro
del Drama así que Pablo estaba más en un
mensaje Universal de Esperanza pero
también estaba mostrando Cuál era la
realidad y quiénes eran las víctimas
reales de la guerra civil y de cualquier
guerra en general
no solo es un poderoso símbolo de la
lucha contra la dictadura franquista
guernica se ha convertido en símbolo de
pacifismo y resistencia en todo el mundo
Cada año tres millones y medio de
personas visitan el cuadro en el Museo
de reina Sofía de Madrid